i'm 18 i keep overthinking about every
relationship trends word
how do i turn down the volume quiet the
voices and just really focus that all
comes from the same place of insecurity
of like not believing in yourself and or
over worrying about what they think
about you which one do you think it is i
mean
of course they kind of work hand-in-hand
right something that i don't like my
girlfriend might not like right what if
she breaks up well let's play it out
what if she breaks up with you you'll be
sad you love her and
life continues i guess you're gonna find
someone else you love yeah but you can't
i don't think that like right now
because i'm 18.
you know there's no 18 excuse here
it's not about being 18. there's people
at 18 that [ __ ] change the world
you're letting fear dictate your actions
you're scared yeah that's okay
everyone's scared i'll flip it on you
the fact that you're 18 and mature
enough to understand that fear is real
that's a strength that means you're
halfway home
the other half way is practicing losing
you've got to start doing [ __ ] that's
scary and have it not work out so you
can [ __ ] taste it got it